faut me ce jeu se joue à deux les
partenaires se font face ils conviennent
de ceux ci la main est tendue doit
serrer représente une feuille de papier
deux doigts écartés figurent une paire
de ciseaux le poing fermé évoque une
pierre enfin le pouce et l'index arrondi
encerclent signifie un puits
chacun de ces symboles l'emportent sur
l'un des trois autres comme l'un des
trois autres peut l'emporter sur lui
ainsi la feuille de papier l'emportent
sur la pierre puisqu'elle l'enveloppent
par contre elle est battue par les
ciseaux qui la découpe
les six ont eux sont battus par la
pierre qui les ai mousse ou par le puits
qui les engloutit le puits à son tour
est recouvert par la feuille de papier
les joueurs cache une main derrière leur
dos au signal
shi fu mi ils présentent simultanément
cette main évoquant l'un des symboles
convenu gagne celui qui l'emportent sur
l'autre shi fu mi la feuille la feuille
depuis le plus ici zoo les groupes la
feuille les ciseaux couple a fait et la
fuite la feuille couvre le puits puis la
valeur et la pierre tombe dans le puits
d'accord ou et mousses les ciseaux
d'accord shi fu mi je gagnais comme pour
moi j ou me garder j'ai gagné cette
manche shifu me ramène pour vous j faut
me c'est nul
gif ou mi août au bénin
c'était j fous mis un jeu pour lequel
nous avons au moins 700 millions de
partenaires
[Musique]